bienvenidos a otro espacio de economía
donde estamos con jorge hurtado para
tratar un tema de suma importancia la
crisis energética que se vive en europa
jorge bienvenido y cuéntenos este
aumento de los precios de la energía
tiene alguna relación con el aumento de
los precios del gas definitivamente la
demanda mundial de gas natural
incremento sin que suba la oferta la
mayoría de europa depende del gas
natural y compite su adquisición con
países asiáticos que ya están comprando
a precios récord la subida de los
precios podría cocinar que suba el resto
de materias primas en el mundo según la
firma de inversión goldman sachs una
consecuencia inmediata manera clara de
esto es el aumento de la factura de luz
en los hogares europeos un ejemplo en
septiembre del 2020 el megavatio/hora en
alemania y francia- costaba un promedio
de 66 dólares este año su precio casi
llega a los 200 dólares los aumentos de
precio de electricidad son drásticos en
francia entre agosto y septiembre
aumentó 149 por ciento en alemania 119
por ciento y en reino unido- 298 por
ciento conversamos antes al respecto con
eric dejar profesor de economía de la
universidad internacional de ciencias
aplicadas de berlín y esto comentó sobre
las alternativas que tienen los países
europeos frente a esta crisis
por otro lado digamos dentro del famoso
tool box o esa caja de herramientas que
menciona la comisión europea también
existe la forma de intervenir las
facturas a través de la reducción de
impuestos por ejemplo a través de la
reducción del impuesto al valor agregado
oliva cuando no hubiera una factura
europea de energía se va a dar cuenta
que más o menos el 50 por ciento como en
el caso de alemania tiene que ver no
realmente con el costo de la energía
sino con los distintos cobros que se
hacen en términos de impuestos y así
sucesivamente entonces al intervenir la
factura reducir esos impuestos se vuelve
una alternativa para que los
consumidores no tengan que pagar tanto
por otro lado la unión europea también
tiene otras formas de ayudar a las
empresas que están viendo sus facturas
explotar prácticamente y es subsidiar
los a través de bonos de co2 que llevan
a que los precios no necesariamente
impacten fuertemente en el proceso
productivo
jorge pero la pelea no es solo no sólo
es con asia como nos comentaba en un
principio las compañías de europa
también tienen una pugna entre si
definitivamente con el cliente gasístico
ruso gazprom respondió a la ucraniana
naftogaz que lo acusó de profundizar el
déficit de gas en europa la gasística
rusa aseguró que las acusaciones son
absurdas y que al contrario las
exportaciones rusas aumentaron un 23% en
comparación con el año pasado son un
medio para clara las exportaciones de
gas natural a europa alcanzó niveles
récords históricos en el primer semestre
europa volvió 17 mil 200 millones de
metros cúbicos de gas ruso un 22 por
ciento más que el mismo período anterior
la empresa premian a alega que rusia
quiere presionar para conseguir la
activación del polémico gasoducto nord
stream 2 que transportará gas ruso hacia
alemania directamente sin pasar por el
territorio ucraniano un multimillonario
proyecto al que eeuu actualmente se
opone eric dejar también nos comparte
qué tiene que ver esta disputa con el
aumento del precio de energía
tienen que ver con la disponibilidad de
gas y eso también se relaciona con una
decisión geopolítica que está anclada en
la provisión de gas desde rusia hacia
europa a través del gasoducto que se
llama norte string 2 esto ha estado ya
hace muchos años en discusiones pero
básicamente el problema tiene que ver
con la incertidumbre que hay de la
provisión de gas y a la vez con la
escasez del gas cuanto más escasos sean
gas más va a costar por otro lado el
problema central del aumento de los
precios de la energía tiene que ver con
el efecto que se da para los
consumidores porque las empresas tienen
que pagar facturas más caras y eso lleva
a que puedan aumentar sus precios pero
jorge mientras las empresas están en
este tira y afloje que están diciendo
los gobiernos bueno reino unido está
considerando préstamos estatales a
compañías de energía según el secretario
de comercio de esa región el 22 de
septiembre la unión europea anunció la
creación de una caja de herramientas
para afrontar las subidas del precio el
15 de septiembre el gobierno de francia
anunció planes para dar un pago de 100
euros a familias con los cheques de
energía
o ayudas para pagar la factura españa
pidió la unión europea la creación de
una plataforma centralizada para comprar
gas también aprobó medidas de emergencia
para dirigir más de 2.600 millones de
euros de la ganancia de las empresas de
energía para los consumidores gracias
jorge por esta información y ustedes
continúen con más información y con más
datos en france24 donde siempre estamos
con ustedes
[Música]
ah